allez c'est parti notre premier débat
avec françoise degois bonsoir et
éditorialiste essayiste vous publiez
l'homme qui n'avait pas d'amis c'est
chez plon et comme on le voit sur la
couverture cds manuel macron qu'il
s'agit bruno cautrès bonsoir vous êtes
otolithes hologue chercheur cnrs au
cevipof j'accueille allemand peer adrian
bartoli bonsoir bienvenue du directeur
des études politiques chez harris
interactive et lætitia croupissent
politique bonsoir laetitia c'est donc
notre dernier débat dans ce sens public
avant le premier tour de cette
présidentielle et donc vous avez entendu
métier je vais vous demander de vous
mouiller quel candidat formeront le trio
de tête et dans quel ordre d'arrivée
françoise degois eh ben c'est très
difficile écouter pour la première fois
je pense que autour de cette table il ya
des grandes probabilités pour que
emmanuel macron malgré son petit
toboggan son toboggan ma main savez les
cinétiques les courbes ne ment pas à
combler une courbe qui descend lentement
vous allez y et notes qui montent en
flèche celle de marine le pen est une
ode qui montrent assez vite celle de
jean luc mélenchon vous vous dites si je
suis manuel macron heureusement qu on
vote dimanche heureusement qu'il ya pas
une semaine de plus bon donc là mais je
moi en toute sincérité je ne sais pas
quel est le tiercé pourquoi parce que il
ya dans cette campagne des inconnus
comment va fonctionner le vote utile on
est dans une centrifugeuse savez jean
luc mélenchon est en train de dépecer
tous les autres candidats de gauche on
voit dans les enquêtes mais pas
simplement harris interactive on voit
bien que jadot baisse yannick jadot
fabien roussel anne hidalgo mais il a
encore du grain à moudre chez les
abstentionnistes est-ce que marine le
pen est surévalué ou pas est-ce que
marine le pen bénéficie du vote utile
par rapport au bulletin eric zemmour il
est possible également et est-ce qu'il
va y avoir un vote utile également
emmanuel macron si des électeurs
considèrent qu'il ya un véritable danger
l'extra mal donc je vous le dis c'est
pas pour pas brouiller parce que non
mais c'est intéressant pour moi la somme
des inconnus de l'ordre d'arrivée à
priori c'est le pen macron mais je n'en
suis pas si sûr je pense que jean luc
mélenchon encore une chance d'être au
second tour avec justement ces 24 ou 25
emmanuel macron je ne sais pas le pen le
pen mac remue mélenchon ce serait
extraordinaire au sens premier du oui
mais alors ce serait surprenant quand
même rires adrien parce que l'écart si
on regarde l'écart c'est vous c'est
d'autres intérieur entre emmanuel macron
et
jean luc mélenchon il est quand même
nous semble en tout cas bien sûr bien
sûr ans vont être rattrapés en trois
jours il est important alors ça c'est un
fait quand on regarde les chiens après
il faut aussi regarder la dynamique
c'est vrai quel manuel macron depuis
plusieurs semaines recule alors au début
c'est un recul assez lent 1 051 points
laon le recul s'accélère assez nettement
sa le maintien à un niveau plus élevé de
la ville était avant la guerre donc
malgré tout ce stock de 24 25 % des
lecteurs qu'on mesure depuis des mois et
des mois nous avec challenge dès qu'il a
senti
la vie 24' ça il fait 24 ce socle là
pour le coup est encore présent et on
est parvenu à ce niveau là même si on se
rapproche de plus en plus mais la
dynamique est quand même baissière et
puis c'est vrai que marine le pen d'un
côté et jean luc mélenchon de l'autre
progresser progresse quand même
fortement on est sur des plus simples
6007 points en quelques semaines entre
et très peu de temps après oui l'écart
est sereine très important et on n'a pas
le tiercé dans l'ordre mais il ya des
chances quand même faisait ce qu'on voit
en tout cas c'est l'électorat qui
s'agrège de plus en plus c'est qu'ils
ont de plus en plus stable avec des
écarts entre les les candidats qui font
l'art est difficile dans les jours qui
restent de complètement renversé la
tendance quelle marge d'erreur je sais
pas si ça veut dire grand chose mais
quelle marge d'erreur parce que quand
même il faut il faut l'intégrer à la
réflexion quand on quand on lit un
sondage mais pour l'instant pour ses
trois premiers candidats oui on n'est
pas dans des cars qui relève de la marge
d'erreur ça c'est sûr qu'en revanche il
ya toute une part des lecteurs qui sont
encore indécis faut pas oublier une un
chiffre assez intéressant il a cinq ans
on a un tiers des électeurs qui se sont
décidées dans les derniers jours alors
attention c'est un tiers qui hésite et
probablement entre un candidat de gauche
à un autre candidat de gauche ou bien de
droite et d'extrême droite en tout cas
c'est pas des basculements totaux de du
paysage politique mais néanmoins les
gens sont pas totalement sûr et vu la
type de campagne qu'on a eu vu les
élections intermédiaires qui sont passés
qui ont quand même beaucoup bousculé les
choses il n'est pas improbable que ce
niveau d'incertitude et décision la
dernière minute soit encore plus élevée
cette fois-ci bruno cautrès au trio de
tête est peut-être une impression un peu
général sur sur cette campagne
présidentielle on sait déjà qui est sur
le podium par contre il est plus
difficile de savoir qui sera sur la
marche 1 2 et 3 on sait déjà qui sera
sur le podium maintenant les cas est
quand même très très important au plan
statistique entre les trois le trio de
tête et l'ensemble des autres candidats
il n'y aura pas de vote caché zemmour
qui d'un seul coup exploserait sont
clairement pas suffisamment pour le voit
la valeur dans son score par deux d'un
seul coup divisant le score d d d d
autre part par 2 également il ya
beaucoup de données qui ont été
produites je n'ai pas en tête le nombre
de sondages a été produit mais c'est
plusieurs centaines de sondages qui ont
été produits du simple pas eu la théorie
statistiques plusieurs centaine
d'observations c'est quand même ça
constitue une vraie évidences empiriques
donc le podium en haut lieu on le
connaît par contre c'est vrai qui reste
une incertitude sur la position que
chacun va occuper sur le podium où vous
dites que marine le pen peut-être devant
emmanuel macron éventuellement exclure
totalement quand on prend en compte ce
que françoise disais tout à l'heure
c'est effectivement cette dynamique on
voit bien qu'une dynamique est très
importante des chiffres de progression
de marine le pen vient d'être rappelée
dans les derniers jours c'est quand même
très impressionnant et donc on voit qu
emmanuel macron est plutôt sur la
descente on voit parallèlement emmanuel
macron sa campagne ou sa non compagne ne
marque pas beaucoup les esprits pour le
moment donc ya pas dans y'a pas de
motivation je dirais d'un seul coup pour
le premier tour le deuxième tour sera
prédisaient encore une autre le premier
tour de dire il faut sauver le soldat
macron dans son électorat donc pour le
moment c'est vrai que c'est un scénario
qu'on ne peut pas exclure le fait qu'ils
soient très proches l'un de l'autre
peut-être plus proches qu'ils ne l'ont
été en 2010 est métissée à votre temps
j'ai aimé votre enthousiasme thomas en
début de cette émission quand vous nous
parler du tourbillon de
pas de tourbillon en fait le plus grand
candidat saison d'âge on n'a parlé que
de son âge pendant les quatre derniers
mois on va dire il n'y a pas de fait
vraiment marquant à part cette méthode
aux rites zemmour mais c'était à
l'automne dernier enfin depuis le début
de l'année 2022 très honnêtement bon
bien sûr il ya eu la guerre en ukraine
qui a tout à succès mais quand même on
voit bien que dans cette campagne
finalement on va certainement rejouer ce
match enfin en tout cas c'est ce qui est
dit donc l'affiché déjà connus donc
c'est pour ça qu'il y aura dans le même
intention 1017 avoue oui et je pense
qu'il y en aura de l'abstention parce
qu'il ya aussi cette affiche qui qui qui
a rejoué à nouveau et dont on dit à quoi
bon voilà il ya toujours ce truc de
rejouer le même scénario bas ça excite -
est-ce qu'un vote cacher effectivement
pour eric zemmour crd des gens comme ils
l'ont ils ont pu le faire pendant des
années quand on évoquait le vote le pen
jean-marie où marine le pen voilà ne ne
pas assumer devant devant vos équipes le
fait de voter des mois par définition
s'il y avait un votre cash et on le
verrait pas dans les études mais après
on peut s'interroger sur différentes
choses on peut notamment penser au
profil des électeurs qui aujourd'hui
choisi ce riz zemmour les électeurs qui
sont quand même plutôt connu pour avoir
l'impression que personne ne parle des
vrais problèmes en france à des
problèmes d'identité
et donc c'est plutôt des gens qui sont
prêts à prendre la parole quand on leur
donne plutôt qu'à se cacher attendre la
dernière minute pour aller voter moi je
crois assez peu honnêtement à cette
théorie d'un grand vote cacher qui plus
est nous votre est le disait que l'écart
est très important aujourd'hui entre
ces demies à neuf et demi pourrait
passer les dix souffle aux retraités 12
par exemple là on pourrait dire qu'il ya
une petite ça c'est aussi votre cash et
c'est sûr qu'il ne part d'incertitude et
qui peut y avoir des électorats qui
fluctuent surtout que c'est un candidat
nouveaux skis et patrick rein parce que
le classement entre lui et valérie
pécresse fr exemple ça ça aura quelques
conséquences france je je je crois alors
je suis absolument d'accord avec
laeticia pour dire que ça a été une
campagne épouvantable éprouvante et
d'ailleurs il ya une forme de servitude
volontaire même de notre part finalement
on a contribué nous mêmes dans la façon
dont on l'a pas nous parce que mes
livres en chaîne par exemple en
organisant pas de débat rien que le fait
que les candidats ne puisse pas débattre
entre je parle pas de la présence du
candide les maquereaux mais ne puisse
pas débattre entre eux c'est quelque
chose de très éprouvant parce que la
france aime le débat il aurait fallu
faire plus de débat sur
les douze candidats ensemble alors moi
je parlais de débat face à face aux
douze candidats ensemble ça n'avait
jamais ça il contient un président
sortant n'a jamais ce que ç'a eu lieu en
2017 tf1 en plus double son score non
mais il n'y avait pas de président
sortant parce que garder au françois
hollande qu'il n'y était pas moins
d'importance c'est le président je la
change pas la vie y est mais non moi je
crois que vraiment nom de ça on a series
lisez aseptisé cette campagne on l'a
complètement écrasée et vous vous
retrouvez avec des dvd des médias même
et nous mêmes qui sommes à
contre-courant de l'as de la volonté des
français les français voulaient qu'on
leur parle de politique de l'ukraine
s'est passée très loin dans les
préoccupations et ses lacets c'est le
pouvoir d'achat qui est venu en premier
c'est même la ferme à keynes et j'étais
sidéré de voir la préoccupation des
français arrivent à 30% et aux faux
finalement tous nous avons tous
participé si vous voulez à 7 à 7
panneaux d'ailleurs à mais je dirais les
grands monstres médiatiques ont
participé à cela et moi je crois
contrairement à ce que prévoient les
sondeurs mais peut-être où seraient
d'accord je pense qu'il va y avoir un
sursaut sur l'abstention et je pense que
la balle de match qu'on appelle la balle
de match dans des dents les politiques
c'est à dire ce qui se passe dans l'urne
le jour j dans l'isoloir qui n'est pas
dans l'ue on en est mort qui n'est pas
comment dirais-je mesurable par les
sondeurs et qui les plantes assez
souvent je pense que cette année c'est
ça c'est pour ça que je me permets on
vous dit qu'il y aura une abstention
sont plus faibles que fait on va être
moins moi ou que 29% et je pense c'est
pour ça que je ne veux pas donner le
sait pas parce que j'ai un d dire que la
gauche au second tour mais je dis
sincèrement que je ne peux pas donner le
tiercé parce que je n'avais pas si c'est
marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon seconde
bruno cautres et sciences proton se
projette pardon un peu plus loin et je
reste sur la la question de d'eric
zemmour qui a été s quand même le voilà
le personnage nouveau on va dire de
cette campagne
oui on pourrait considérer que fabien
roussel aussi mais à un degré moindre à
fait a fait irruption il s'installe pour
longtemps dans la tradition d'une
certaine extrême orthez que c'est lui
l'héritier politique de jean-marie le
pen finalement aujourd'hui certainement
beaucoup dit au vu de ses déclarations
aussi au vu du profil des lecteurs qui
l'a qui l'attirent oui il couvre une
partie de ce qui a été le front national
de jean marie le pen quand on dit les
front national du nord et celui du sud
on est plutôt au sud il a un profil les
lecteurs plutôt seniors des travailleurs
indépendants des petits commerces dont
une clientèle électorale que le
rassemblement national au moment du
front national a très bien connu et donc
il arrive à prendre aussi une part de
cette droite sioniste qui était vraiment
sur l'idée qu'on avait volé l'élection
en tout cas que
françois fillon avait été la victime
d'une sorte de complot judiciaire et
donc il arrive à capter cette
frustration d'une partie de l'histoire
de la droite est incontestablement il
s'inscrit dans le paysage alors après il
aura quand même d'un enjeu important
c'est comment s'inscrit-il dans le
paysage est ce qui va se présenter aux
élections législatives arrivera-t-il à
être élu député ça change complètement
s'il est élu député ou s'ils restent
simplement le leader d'une formation
politique ça sera pas du tout la même
chose quelle concurrence aura t-il dans
son camp si marion marshall revient en
politique si elle est élue députée pas
lui qu'est ce que ça fait voilà donc qui
s'inscrit dans le paysage
incontestablement et je souscris à
l'idée que effectivement il n'y a pas
beaucoup de renouvellement sur les douze
candidats il y en a 7 7 qui était déjà
là en 2012 et sur les sept de 2012 y en
a cinq qui en sort la troisième
candidature bien sûr ça fait beaucoup
c'est vrai il ya alors lui représente
effectivement quelque chose de nouveau
un courant de pensée qui existe dans la
vie politique française après l'analyse
il aura lui même son rejeton il aurait
lui-même sont son son audience et ses
propres contradictions parce que quand
on regarde la position d'eric zemmour
par rapport aux autres candidats de
droite on voit que sur l'économie il est
libéral freddy pécresse ou même de
macron sur certains points sur la
dimension sociétale il s'éloigne d'eux
est donc à un moment donné lui aussi il
sera un peu ce quiz et parce qu'il n'a
cessé de dénoncer c'est à dire un
clivage interne à la droite sur les
questions économiques et sur les
questions culturelles va dépendre des 8
heures de caisse qui dirige zemmour à
20h02 qu'est-ce qui dirige les mots il
dit à titre personnel j'appelle à voter
marine le pen il dit j'appelle amplifier
l'élan de marine le pen si elle est
devant il se il se fit scène
complètement eric zemmour il a passé
finalement une campagne expliquez vous
savez celle là l'est trop belle trop
blonde est trop débile pour pouvoir
gagner de façon elle gagnera jamais il
finit à 7 8 5 peut-être six parce que au
rythme nous avons le dépeçage et le vote
utile dans les derniers moments je ne
sais pas à combien y sera mais certaines
peut-être pas à 10 qu'est-ce qui fait
rêver moore intervenus à 20h15 à 20h30
c'est son avenir dépend des mots qu'il
va prononcer son avenir personnel
politique dépendent des mots qui va
prononcer la soirée électorale joensuu
électorale à 19h30 soyez là jusqu'à
minuit
je me tue de plus belle ces faits public
sénat ça va être passionnant c'est
passionnant de guéret d'analysé on aura
beaucoup de d'experts de politologues
sociologues danel d'historiens
d'analyser les mots des candidats sont
qualifiés 19 ce que laissent prévoir ce
soir il est à 18 6 jean luc mélenchon
finalement n'arrivent pas selon son
souhait accroché le second tour avec les
dents que fait-il jean luc mélenchon si
la
seule fois ni la dernière fois on a fait
la soirée électorale la même hilali pas
une seule voie pour marine le pen
ballack c'est ce qu'il a dit la dernière
fois est ce que il dit ça aussi il
grande partie de la réélection des
macros pourrait dépendre de la route
jean luc mélenchon on est on y verra
tout à l'heure avec mario viau sur les
stratégies de 20 heures une ou deux
vainqueurs de mes jours et qu'on
revienne sur les mots laetitia puisque
vous décortiquer le mot de la semaine
sur nos réseaux sociaux depuis la
rentrée de janvier alors là vous en avez
retenu 5
pour en quelque sorte donné le ton de
cette présidentielle c'est très
subjectif parce que c'était déjà une
sélection que j'avais faite depuis le
mois de janvier alors j'en ai retenu
cinq par ordre chronologique le premier
ceimi ça est ce que vous vous rappelez
de sélectionner milk était parti en
flèche début janvier à cause des
vacances de noël du ministre de
l'éducation nationale
on croyait que c'était anecdotique non
la charge symbolique d'ibiza elle est
très lourde et tout le gouvernement le
savez bien sûr que c'est d'une image de
déconnexion de privilèges qui
l'entouraient et donc il ya vraiment eu
une communication de crise mise en place
avec jean michel blanquer lui-même son
plateau tf1 devant les députés avec la
promesse de ne dire ibis a qu'une seule
fois et ensuite c'est valérie pécresse
qui prendra alors là c'est vous la
connaissez cette communication politique
très classique gros rouge qui tache
valérie pécresse qui ressort le kärcher
de nicolas sarkozy de la cave et qui
dans la même phrase parle de racaille
donc on avait tout le vocabulaire
sarkozyste est bon in fine et ça lui a
pas du tout servir valérie pécresse
nicolas sarkozy ne l'a jamais soutenu
ouvertement il l'a même critiqué à
longueur de papiers dans la presse et
dans les médias et puis cette position
finalement très adroite de valérie
pécresse l'a totalement corner remisé le
mot guerre que si le mot guerre dans la
bouche de tous les candidats évidemment
comme je sais tout à l'heure elle a
asphyxié la campagne et puis finalement
elle a changé aussi un peu de braquet
d'habitude on était très franco français
alors la campagne présidentielle ce qui
est tout à fait normal l'international
en général vous le savez bien pour
présenter des éditions depuis longtemps
ça n'intéresse quasiment personne en
général on a du mal à faire des
audiences sur ce sujet et là les
français se sont passionnés par ce que
c'est une guerre évidemment aux portes
de l'europe et il ya eu des positions
plus compliqué à défendre celle de jean
luc mélenchon celle de marine le pen
bien sûr d'eric zemmour mais lui est
resté droit dans ses bottes par rapport
à la condamnation ou pas
la dîmière poutine et lé fait très
rarement de la part de jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen nommément
d'ailleurs qu'il condamne la russie mais
pas vladimir poutine et puis dans la
dernière ligne droite un argent majid
emmanuel macron et puis le mot migration
pour examen oui j'ai choisi ça parce que
c'est assez symptomatique justement de
ces derniers jours eric zemmour qui
échoue qui vraiment qui chutent un
lamentablement et puis à 200 fait sur
sur la dernière ligne droite parce
qu'ils s'enferment dans cette son
obsession du grand remplacement avec ce
terme de hre migration qui l inverse du
processus d'immigration est donc
finalement c'est à lui qu'il devra son
échec et puis l'argent magique de
d'emmanuel macron qui montre que il
s'est drapé dans cette étoffe de chef
des armées de dudu du chef de la france
face à la menace de la guerre en ukraine
et qu'il refuse finalement de descendre
dans l'arène
faire concurrence à marine le pen sur le
sujet du pouvoir d'achat il dit argent
magique c'est une expression fétiche
pour le président sortant et elle est
complètement contradictoire avec sa
politique de quoi qu'il en coûte pendant
le coc vide vous voyez bien que l'argent
magique ça veut dire écoutez on peut pas
non plus dépenser comme ça on n'a pas de
l'argent ça pousse pas dans les arbres
sauf que pendant le coc vide il a sauvé
selon lui est la france grâce à sa
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte on sait
une limite peut-être de sa stratégie
nyon en même temps bruno cautrès moi
j'aurais retenir le mot le mot et voir
ce que vous en pensez est ce que ces six
semaines déjà six semaines de guerre ans
en ukraine on selon vous profondément
modifié les équilibres les équilibres
politiques de cette campagne de premier
tour elle l'on me dit si à un moment
donné quand emmanuel macron a profité à
plein de cet effet on appelle fait du
drapeau ou là incontestablement ça a
permis à emmanuel macron de prendre une
distance considérable dans les
intentions de vote il est monté au delà
de 30 % donc un score très important qui
rappellent à ce moment là certains ses
prédécesseurs qui avaient obtenu des
scores flirtant avec les 30 % ou
dépassant 30% dans lequel nicolas
sarkozy même donc effectivement à ce
moment là ça change quelque chose et
puis ça change aussi parce que tout le
monde à un moment donné est obligé de
venir jouer sur le terrain du présent de
la république de se positionner par
rapport à ça ça réorganise le débat de
la campagne ça oblige les différents
candidats à parler d'europe ça les
oblige pas la politique étrangère ce
qu'il faisait très peu ça oblige une
certaine manière a tombé le masque sur
les questions européennes en particulier
et donc ça a changé quelque chose
rapidement les faits s'est évaporée
d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait conforme à
ce qui explique la la la la la théorie
de ce ralliement derrière le drapeau qui
a été inventé au début des années 70 et
qui dit que cet effet n'a pas vocation à
perdurer et que si la crise s'éternise
les faits devient même négatif au bout
d'un moment parce que les citoyens les
électeurs disent mais finalement ils
n'arrivent pas à gérer la crise elle
s'éternise donc emmanuel macron voit que
l'effet drapeau même temps c'est
totalement évaporés pratiquement et donc
il est maintenant effectivement revenu
un niveau qui était celui de avant la
guerre à nouveau chapitre dans ce débat
on pourrait titrer ou parler d'eux
de 20h de monsieur de 20 heures une
contre madame 20h02 ont pour reprendre
les amabilités échangées entre eric
zemmour et et valérie pécresse l'une
supposé se rallier à emmanuel macron dès
20h deux puits et l'autre supposer ce
rallye fiable et de le pen dès 20h on
verra bien ce qui se donne bref mari au
lit re bonsoir marion on parle tout de
suite des ralliements au soir du premier
tour oui puisque depuis trois semaines
la candidate du rassemblement national
connaît une dynamique forte sa
progression ne s'effrite pas
contrairement au chef de l'état
conséquence avec ce retour en force du
rn les appelle à faire barrage à
l'extrême droite réapparaissent et déjà
certains candidats donnent quelques
pistes quant à leur position en cas de
duel macron le pen et c'était le cas ce
matin d'anne hidalgo écoutez là
moi j'appellerai de toute façon à faire
barrage à l'extrême droite ça c'est ma
boussole et je le ferai mais nous ne
sommes pas encore au soir du premier
tour
une position que partage de yannick
jadot qui répète qu'il ne faut pas
précipiter les choses néant le front
républicain restera la ligne directrice
des verts idem pour fabien roussel le
candidat communiste quant à jean luc
mélenchon et bien rien n'est tranché
souvenez-vous en 2010 est le candidat
insoumis n'avait donné aucune consigne
de vote pour le second tour il avait à
l'époque déclaré je cite chacun et
chacune d'entre vous on sait en
conscience qu'elle est son devoir et
cette fois ci pour ce scrutin il estime
que la question ne se pose pas car il
est convaincu d'être qualifié dans le
cas contraire il compte néanmoins
consulter ses soutiens voici ce qu'il
confiait au journal le télégramme
trois cent dix mille personnes par haine
ma candidature donc le soir du premier
tour on leur demandera ce que l'on fait
pour le deuxième et à droite du côté de
valérie pécresse est bien la candidate
et républicains refusent de répondre à
cette question elle martèle qu'elle sera
au second tour mais en même temps
qu'elle sait prendre ses responsabilités
mais qu'en sera-t-il de son parti ait
l'air une fracture risque en effet de se
dessiner entre les maquereaux
compatibles et la frange plus radicale
porté par bruno retailleau eric ciotti
laurent wauquiez qui ne seront sûrement
pas favorable à un report des voix en
faveur du candidat président on pourrait
donc s'orienter vers une stratégie du ni
ni ni macro ni le pen un bureau
politique est prévu chez les élèves au
lendemain du premier tour à la décision
pourrait se prendre à ce moment là le
score de la candidate et notamment sa
place par rapport à eric zemmour devrait
également peser dans la balance marine
le pen sur qui pourra t elle compter et
bien pour la première fois elle dispose
d'une réserve de voix non négligeable
via le report des suffrages à d'eric
zemmour un candidat qui a d'ores et déjà
déclaré philippe qu'il était ouvert au
dialogue qu'il réfléchit à une alliance
avec le rassemblement national mais ce
n'est pas ce qu'envisage le rn écouter
son porte-parole sébastien chenu il
intervenait ce matin dans la matinale de
public c'est la télé c'est la logique de
la vème république c'est la rencontre
entre une candidate en l'occurrence et
les français pas par l'intermédiaire des
partis politiques je
discutais avec nicolas
vous avez pas porter votre
marine le pen un dialogue direct avec
les français sébastien chenu qui a en
revanche évidemment appelé les militants
du candidat reconquête à rejoindre le rn
pour battre emmanuel macron merci mario
à tout à l'heure pour une autre
chronique dans ce débat pierre adrien
bartoli sur les les reports il ya quand
même c'est quelque chose que vous eva
lui régulièrement depuis plusieurs
semaines et celle et là on se bat ce qu
on bascule évidemment les enjeux du
second tour il ya effectivement un
réservoir de voix qui est beaucoup plus
important cette année qui a cinq ans
pour marine le pen et pas seulement
parce que là on parlait beaucoup des
règlements pas seulement du côté de
laboratoire ou de l'extrême droite non
c'est sûr enfin on va évidemment parler
de ça il faut déjà dire que quand on
n'est pas encore en situation donc c'est
ce qui est plus probable au regard des
enquêtes mais n'est pas sûre que ce soit
effectivement ce qui va se passer au
second tour et puis les enquêtes de
second tour fait avant le premier tour
doivent être prises quand même avec un
peu de distance ça je trouve ça très
bien mais ne disiez ça pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi il faut les prendre avec des
pincettes csq est ce parce que ça reste
des hypothèses c'est que les gens se
prononce sur quelque chose qui n'est pas
l'offre politique réelle à ce stade et
ils ont déjà du mal à se projeter dans
le premier tour dans le second tour au
russe est encore plus loin ceci dit
est-ce que ça n'a aucune valeur je crois
pas non plus ça nous donne des
indications sur là où en sont les
électeurs et où est-ce qu'ils en sont
aujourd'hui premièrement marine le pen
elle arrive avec une certaine dynamique
au second tour si elle est qualifiée
parce qu'elle l'aurait un niveau soit
proche de celui qu'elle a eue il ya cinq
ans soit même certains disent dans sa
phase de cette étude notamment celles
qu'on a sorti cette semaine un niveau
plus élevé ce niveau plus élevé il
arrive avec un socle électoral assez
bien consolider mais aussi un apport des
lecteurs fillonniste dès le premier tour
dont des gens de droite l'aurait jamais
voté fn jusqu'à présent ou et rennes et
qui cette fois ci se reprendrait dès le
premier temps sur marine le pen donc un
socle plus stable plus large et puis et
c'est là que ça devient vraiment
intéressant un oeuf 10% d'eric zemmour
qui à 85 % se transférer sur marine le
pen au second tour donc là il n'y a pas
de barrière ou de freins ou votre marine
le pen quand on est homo et humoriste ou
en 2022 deuxièmement une perméabilité où
il ya un souhait de voter marine le pen
au sein des électorats valérie pécresse
d'une part et jean luc mélenchon donc on
va vraiment très loin d'autre part que
non négligeable on a un carrosse au
milieu de ses électeurs qui aujourd'hui
nous disent pourquoi pas au second tour
voter pour marine le pen et puis et
c'est la troisième grosse inconnue c'est
évidemment l'attention alors on avait
déjà vu il ya cinq ans une ascension en
progression et blancs et nuls d'ailleurs
très haut au sien entre le premier tour
et le second tour cette fois ci on a des
électeurs de gauche qui nous disent
entre 1/3 et 50% selon les catégories
d'électeurs qu'au fond ils ont peut-être
pas envie d'aller voter utile donc voté
pour emmanuel macron secondes on laisse
les autres faire le choix ce qui fait
qu'on arrive à des niveaux de second
tour aujourd'hui encore très
hypothétique évidemment on l'a dit de
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
qui les met presque au coude à coude le
vote blanc
c'est vrai qu'on n'en parle jamais il
n'existait pas et il ya des gens qui
vont aller voter mais aller voter blanc
pour dire ben dans l'offre politique la
personne signe des temps si vous
permettez parce que c'est bien ce qu'a
fait je voudrais juste corriger la
déclaration réel de jean luc mélenchon
s'est pas il voit pour marine le pen je
le dis parce qu'on a l'impression que ça
c'était le soir à 20 heures quand il a
fait ça à 20 heures locales quand il
prend la parole dit pas une voix pour
marine le pen donc cette phrase on l'a
oublié mais c'est malheureux de l'avoir
oublié autres cas ont leur billet
deuxièmement je pense très dangereux que
à trois jours nous soyons en train de
faire ce genre d'hypothèse et je vous
rejoins et second tours n'existe pas à
partir du moment où le premier tour
n'est pas joué il est impossible de se
positionner il ya un tel trouble est là
qu'elle a oublié de noter mais c'est
normal parce qu'elle avait qu'à faire la
politique moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est le
medef le medef qui dit nous nous
réunirons le 11 avril c'est le medef en
2010 est systématiquement en soutien des
modèles macron il s'était même prononcé
avant la et génie dit comment ces
inédits que le medef soutiennent à
angers elle vient à l'instant c'est il
est dit que le medef ne soit pas dans le
systématique et le medef a annoncé qu'il
ferait un bureau le 11 avril pour
annoncer une décision il ya quand même
quelque chose là qui est en train de
bouger et je le redis nous ne savons pas
quel sera ce second tour il ya de fortes
chances face à macro le pen nous ne
savons pas dans quel sens imaginez
marine le pen qui qui écarte sur
emmanuel macron de 2,3 points qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est là là on
est vraiment dans donc je crois que
vraiment restons quand même sur ce
premier tour et ses chances de métaux
parce que je pense que les électeurs de
toute façon je le redis je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce qui se cuisinent au fond la
marmite mais c'est pas forcément coin
évidemment on a toujours cette prudence
reste
je voudrais peut-être sur le sur le vote
clair si vous pouvez parler d'un d'une
réunion de délégués du medef le lundi
aussi un bureau politique chez l air qui
va
petit sourire parce que ça va être ça va
être compliqué là il ya des lignes de
fracture qui vont voilà potentiellement
faire imploser ce parti comme quand vous
les lignes de fracture et puis a
évidemment
celui qui est dans l'ombre nicolas
sarkozy
qui semble faire un autre choix au fond
me semble-t-il qui est plutôt le choix
d'un
pragmatique de direction peut-être de
faire un deal avec le président macron
s'il est réélu et à ce moment là qui tue
un tout autre perspective stratégique
qui au fond d'accepter la réalité
si emmanuel macron été réélu et
d'essayer de sauver les républicains en
devenant une partie de la majorité quand
tout autre choix stratégiques bien
évidemment évidemment pour que ce choix
stratégique soit comestibles digérable
parler l air les militants les cadres du
parti il faut obtenir quelque chose
évidemment en échange ce ne peut pas
être comme ça donc il faut qu'ils
obtiennent quelque chose en échange et
ça c'est assez suspendue aux résultats
des élections législatives
donc les résultats des élections du
statut vous rend rôle absolument
fondamental de ce point de vue là sur la
stratégie les élèves y en a un qui n en
embuscade il me semble de l air de 7 ce
naufrage lrc edouard philippe parce que
pour l'instant sa formation politique
est tout petit mais s'il a un coût
politique à jouer c'est bien sûr de
récupérer cette droite qui est étanche
et qui reste étanche avec l'extrême
ratio le rappeler quand même qu'il ya
une grosse partie des républicains qui
ne veut pas dans aucun cas pactiser avec
l'extrême droite et puis il ya la jeune
génération on parle beaucoup de david
higgins tard ce qui se murmure en tout
cas chez les à l'heure c'est que le
lallé l air de là les républicains vous
peuvent exister comme une entité à part
entière pas du tout être avalés par la
machine macro et est vraiment se
reconstruire avec cette nouvelle
génération david lisnard fait partie de
ces étoiles montantes de la droite sur
laquelle servant de cette droite et du
week-end vous parle il ferait bien un
composé très bien qu'ils ne pactise pas
qu'il est maladroite de wauquiez qui
n'est pas la droite de ciotti et qui dit
nous avons une existence propre il faut
tout reconstruire ils peuvent encore
l'envisager pour ça il faut être
au-dessus de la barre symbolique de 10
thomas pardonnez moi je dit valérie
pécresse d'abord il faut qu'elle soit
devant eric zemmour ça c'est une
question de survie même un poil et un
epsilon et il faut être au dessus de 10
vraiment en dessous de 10 ça paraît très
compliqué sa survie à elle je sais même
pas elle va revenir je me demande
d'ailleurs comment anne hidalgo pourra
revenir à la mairie on ne peut pas on
peut pas balayer tous les enjeux mais y
en a tellement qui sont passionnants il
ya effectivement anne hidalgo comment
assez logique de même de pouvoir comment
on reprend la main à la mairie de paris
mais valérie pécresse à la région à la
mairie paris justement la chance dans le
malheur d'anne hidalgo sera que yannick
jadot est parti pour faire un score en
dessous de 5 donc là si vous voulez le
rapport de force il est il est quasiment
suite 5 le ps est ruiné kenza d'argent
non non le ps le ps a vendu solférino le
ps a obtenu des prêts y'a pas tous qui a
couru en 10 ans non l héparine et ça
leur a coûté cher mais elle a fait vous
remarquerez que le ps a fait une
campagne quand même très low cost alors
vous parliez d'une via ninja nous on va
faire un zoom sur le vote jeunes si vous
le voulez bien vote des 18 30 ans il a
dit la doc était sur france inter ce
matin il s'adresse aux jeunes
on a voulu parler de la jeunesse on a
voulu la mobiliser il faut qu'elle
s'empare de cette élection c'est notre
avenir c'est son avenir qui se joue elle
a été tellement précarisés pendant ce
quinquennat il ya tellement de
propositions pour les sortir de la
précarité avec un revenu citoyen pour
leur donner un ticket liberté climat
c'est à dire qu'un ticket il peut se
balader sur tous les transports
collectifs dans notre pays avec une
seule carte à partir de 50 euros de
l'autonomie la fin de la précarité on
s'occupe des grands enjeux de l'humanité
pour eux et pour nous eh ben voilà j'en
aurais aimé en parler plus masculine
alors si l'on en croit les sondages
yanick nadeau il n'a pas réussi à
mobiliser et les jeunes pas seulement
mais les jeunes notamment qui sont
pourtant on peut dire que c'est une
génération qui a ses politiques via les
associations via les leafs et les mêmes
qui manifestent pour pour
l'environnement bruno cautrès sais pas
comment vous vous analysé ce décalage
est il faut pas sous-estimer peu après
j'aurai la parole à pirna dessus le le
fait qu'il ya peut-être une majorité de
18 30 aujourd'hui qui ils votent
prioritairement pour qui pour marine le
pen pour marine le pen la jeunesse qui
est des qualifiés la jeunesse des
travailleurs pauvres jeunes marine le
pen incontestablement l'autre jeunesse
plutôt mélenchon
j'ai ouvert j'ai ouvert la question le
pen mais sur le vote europe écologie les
verts pourquoi ça n'a pas imprimé ou
près de cette génération qui est quand
même pour une large part mobilisés sur
cette caisse sur ces questions ce qui a
une série de problèmes le premier c'est
que si la question du climat de l'avenir
la planète préoccupe beaucoup c'est
numéro deux dans les enjeux qui
préoccupent la manière dont l'écologie
politique en france traite cette
question ne couvrent pas l'ensemble de
la préoccupation écologique pour
beaucoup de français la préoccupation
écologique c'est mieux traiter les
animaux c'est s'occuper
de la nature et le prisme assez politisé
on va dire de l'écologie politique ne
couvrent pas l'ensemble vous avez au
niveau de la base beaucoup
d'associations qui luttent et qui
s'engage pour la protection d'espèces
animales des oiseaux etc et qui voit
cette écologie politique un peu comme un
peu trop idéologie parle parfois par
ailleurs il difficulté de fond le
message politique des écologistes et un
message plutôt de rénovation du lien
politique
l'élection présidentielle c'est quelque
chose qui est difficile parce que le
rôle du présent la république dans la
cinquième c'est une sorte de rôle très
verticale de d'autorité à base de
leadership qui s'affirme et c'est vrai
que les écossais pas dans la culture et
nous propose notre site de liens
politiques plus horizontale plus dans le
dialogue le plus dans le respect de
l'autre il n'y a pas de dialogue ils ont
sorti sandrine rousseau donc m
une autre question et après l'élection
présidentielle c'est une élection
incroyablement intransigeante
impitoyable du point de vue de
l'équation personnelle du candidat
yannick jadot a fait des efforts on voit
il a revêtu le costume du candidat
officiel et ça marche pas quand même
parce que quelque part les électeurs
doivent ressentir que peut-être il
s'inscrit dans une compétition qui n'est
peut-être pas là où yannick jadot peut
donner le meilleur de lui-même et
piranha bartoli lui ce vote jeunes les
18 30 ans
c'est le même trio de tête que pour
l'ensemble des français parfois c'est un
c'est le même trio mais c'est pas les
mêmes proportions oui et on a
effectivement non pas une jeunesse mais
des jeunes est donc effectivement des
votes différents avec un jean luc
mélenchon qui est prend toute sa place
notamment autour de l'enjeu
environnemental qui en fait l'argent que
mélenchon est parvenu à pour ces jeunes
là être le candidat qui portait le mieux
ces enjeux qui effectivement compte à
leurs yeux et puis on a une jeunesse
plus intégrée qui effectivement est une
jeunesse qui va voter pour emmanuel
macron et ça on oublie un petit peu
qu'il a soutenu d'ailleurs durant tout
son quinquennat toute une partie de la
confiance emmanuel macron dans les
différents baromètres mensuels vient de
cette jeunesse qui au final l'a soutenu
presque de manière uniforme tout au long
du quinquennat et puis c'est vrai qu'on
a une part de la jeunesse qui vote
également marine le pen mais elle a un
peu évolué ces dernières années
notamment par un effet de cohorte c'est
plus une jeunesse qui a aujourd'hui
entre 25 et 35 ans plutôt jeunes actifs
plutôt jeunes parents et un peu plus
dans les difficultés de la vie
quotidienne que la génération précédente
on est à dire les moins de 25 ans les
politiques il s'adresse pas beaucoup aux
jeunes dans une campagne présidentielle
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils votent moins
que les autres je sais aussi nos basics
à faire deux pas du tout je me souviens
de ségolène royal qui a fait une
campagne basée pour les jeunes
d'ailleurs elle avait laissé les clefs
de sa campagne à la jeunesse à la
ségosphère notamment thomas hollande son
fils qu'est jean luc mélenchon a fait un
an et demi un point d'honneur à laisser
les clés de sa campagne les gens quand
tous moins de 30 ans c'est pour ça que
ça 2 / directeur de campagne bompard qui
à 33 ans 4 menace mais tout là toute la
sphère numérique cdb il a dit voilà il
d'ailleurs vous voyez le nombre de
jeunes qui assurent les 18 24 ans il est
en tête mélenchon est derrière ces
macron c'est vrai bon ya moi je pense
que c'est une façon de s'adresser je
pense que je suis d'accord sur le sur
l'analyse l'équation personnelle une
présidentielle est impitoyable dans les
quinze derniers jours les gens se disent
bon celui-là est ce que je le vois
président ou pas c'est aussi une
question aussi bête que ça et je pense
que l'anti présidentialisme des verts
rencontre à chaque présidentielle la
logique de la 5e et ça ne fonctionne pas
donc la jeunesse moi je moi je vois
quand même les candidats s'adresse à jet
c'est plus compliqué pour la droite
emmanuel macron s'adresse à la jeunesse
ségolène royal l'a fait françois
hollande en 2012 le fait également et
d'ailleurs il y fait un très bon score
et la jeunesse donc cette jeunesse et le
talent
sarkozy elles demandent qu'à ce qu'est
ce qu'elle demande qu'à s'enflammer la
jeunesse et je suis aussi d'accord sur
le caractère très politique car même
très politicards des verts ressentie
comme telle en tout cas de europe
ecologie les verts la structure yannick
jadot ça fait super bien pour résumer
sur une européenne ça ne le fait pas sur
une présidentielle parce que c'est
impitoyable et dans la dernière semaine
vous verrez c'est mérité pour souffrir
souffre aussi le ça est ce qu'il fait
président ou pas dans la tête des gens
est-ce que s'il fait président ou pas il
s'avère que macro fait président béland
show vieux président et marine le pen
nouvelle présidente dans l'esprit des
gens je pense que c'était un facteur
très important ballon pierre-adrien
bartoli et et les et les programmes dans
tout ça je sais bien qu'on est dans un
système présidentiel que l'umq
l'incarnation
est ce que le fait de recevoir l'aller
les programmes non chez soi est ce
qu'enfin les gens dont on peut les
regarder ou est-ce que ça se regarde
beaucoup ainsi les riads pas tant que ça
si
les gens les regarder le programme
compte mais en fait c'est plutôt le la
trace mémorielle du programme mais ça il
ya un exemple qui illustre bien sa
actuellement on a parlé un petit peu
avec la courbe des manuels macron avec
le team hm une hausse très forte au
moment de la guerre et puis un recul
semaine après semaine depuis mais il
s'est passé un phénomène sous jacent à
cette hausse puis cette baisse assez
lente dès le départ l'entrée en campagne
emmanuel macron on a une hausse plus
forte auprès des électeurs de droite en
gros les électeurs de valérie pécresse à
l'époque ces électeurs là ils viennent
parce qu'ils entendent la petite musique
de manuel macron autour des 65 ans
autour du rsa etc etc c'est être petite
musique là qu'il n'est pas de catalogue
de mesures extrêmement précises ou
maîtrisés par les électeurs sa leaf est
resté aujourd'hui autour d' emmanuel
macron parce qu'ils sont pas repartis
al'inverse des électeurs de gauche qui
est pas plus que ses électeurs de droite
connaît cela le détail du programme et
du pourquoi du comment on entendu aussi
ses messages et ont eu une forme de
doute ce qui a été un peu lisse et où
passait sous le tapis parce que la
guerre la nécessité d'être autour du
président mais aujourd'hui eux sont en
train de retirer leurs billes et de se
dire peut-être qu'au fond emmanuel
macron n'est pas le meilleur candidat
pour moi qui ait une culture politique
de gauche je vais ailleurs donc c'est
pas le programme c'est plutôt la petite
musique qui a sous le programme qui est
elle peut jouer assez fortement ouais
très court il ya une idée reçue aussi on
pense que alors de nos points de vue de
journalistes que les clips vous savez
qu'ils sont diffusés à heure fixe la
société est mignon un public ne servent
à rien et c'est une fausse idée puisque
beaucoup de français se décide et
parfois entre dans la campagne avec la
diffusion de ces clés les découvre
incarnation ces deux minutes c'est bien
fait on comprend on a une incarnation on
voit le candidat qui nous parlent
directement et c'est vrai que la
télévision reste encore aujourd'hui le
média de masse dans une campagne
présidentielle très lourd et moraliser
le taux d' indécision il reste important
il reste trois jours c'est le moment de
faire votre choix si vous l'avez pas
encore fait vous pouvez même encore
faire des procurations ne l'oublié pas
c'est encore possible là et c'est de
plus en plus facile en france donc si
vous pouvez pas vous déplacer trouver
quelqu'un qu'elle est ici vie à votre
place j'espère bien que tout le monde
veut aller voter c'est chaud ça super
look de poires et votez pas oublier
qu'il ya des pays où c'est juste
impossible depuis des décennies à la sas
a vomi deux équipes donc profitons-en
merci françois toulis et l'homme qui
n'avait pas d'amis je sais pas s'il en
aura plus ou moins à 20 heures
on verra bien on verra si c'est aux
éditions plon